But I'm in the middle of the dark on top
of this, you know, this thing in the
cemetery and I'm calling those spirits
[music]
and I'm hearing all type of voices.
I'm hearing voices. I'm hearing animals.
I'm I'm hearing trouble sounds.
And those things [music] are coming into
me.
If you were raised in a family of
witches, how could God get your
attention?
What's up, everybody? Thank you for
joining us again at LED Alive. We got a
really exciting testimony today, but
first I just want to thank all our
Patreon donors, all the people that
support this ministry. We truly cannot
do this without you [music] guys.
There's a lot of ways you can support
us. You can go to Patreon. You can go to
our website for [music] a one-time
donation, or you can buy some really
cool t-shirts that they sell over at
lightwear.shop
and they're really good conversation
starters about you know, sharing your
witness. We call it wearing your
witness. But we want to get into the
story cuz I have my friend Ferme here
who was raised in Haiti and her family
was a family of witches. They [music]
were into witchcraft, is that right?
Yes. Yes. My family I was born in in
Haiti. Yes, and my [music] grandfather,
my
was a chief [music] of of witches.
And it's very common over there.
You know, if he had the authority
[music] because he was a chief
in in that region and of course he
practiced a lot [music] of witchcraft.
And so because of that,
you know, I came right into the world
through the you know, through that
family foundation and and of course
darkness,
[music]
you know,
was the thing that we lived not knowing
that it was so much of darkness because
it was a common way of of life, you
know, until I came
into a relationship with Jesus Christ. I
started to understand the difference
between light and darkness. Then I
understand that I was living a life of
darkness. So you were born in Haiti.
You're born into this culture that
accepts witchcraft as kind of normal.
Here we're kind of, you know, a
Christian nation, quote unquote
Christian, but over there is there any
talk of God or Jesus or is it just all
darkness or how exactly is the culture
there? The [clears throat] well, it is a
Catholic
but it's not really embraced from a
religious perspective. It is, but maybe
maybe a 1%. Okay.
You know, very very small percentage of
people who actually embrace it for what
it is. So is it kind of like just good
luck charms and stuff or something?
Correct. Correct. So we'll go to church,
but it's not really practiced. You know,
I'm a church goer. Some people do not
really get involved in the witchcraft,
but they don't really have the
foundation, the religious foundation
either. Yeah. So they really have no
foundation and so they can easily be
pulled into the place of, you know, of
witchcraft because they don't have
anything from the religious, you know,
perspective to sustain them. And we know
that the ultimate place to find safety
is in God.
And he's given us instructions
in the Bible. We have the instructions
on on how to live safely, not by putting
statues, not by putting things around
our homes. He alone is enough to protect
us.
Now, the Bible says in Deuteronomy
chapter 12,
"Go and break those altars." Mhm. Yeah.
Specifically.
He says, "Go and break those altars."
Who is he telling to go and break those
altars? Those who have the knowledge.
Yeah. Like me and you, right, Mike? Yep.
And that's what we want to do here is we
want to expose darkness. We want to
bring the information to people so that
they can now have the knowledge. Now
the
[clears throat]
the ball's kind of in their court at
that point. Cuz the Bible does talk
about in the New Testament it says that
God winks at our sins committed in
ignorance, but now commands all men to
repent. Once you have the knowledge,
Mhm. it's it's up to you. You have to
make a decision. And you can't choose to
live in ignorance like, "No, if I just
if I don't know, then I can just" No,
it's our duty to seek truth like it's
gold.
I want to know Okay, I really I'm
curious about your story. So you were
raised in Haiti. What's what's your
childhood like? I want to know I want to
hear the whole story from where you were
raised, what kind of things you
experienced, and how God got your
attention to where you're at now. Okay,
well, to tell you my whole story, Mike,
you'd have to read my book.
Okay. Okay, it has yet to be published,
but it will be published as soon.
And that book will be the power of
agreement, how to agree with God and,
you know, be in that place of light and
safety. But
just to give you a little
just a little bit about my testimonies.
Yes, I was born
in Haiti. I came here to the United
States um
46 years ago. How old were you when you
came to the States?
Okay. I'm I'm now 60 years old, thank
God.
Is it a big culture shock? I don't know
anything about Haiti. Is it like third
world or city or
Yeah, third world. Okay, like what kind
of like houses or like dirt floors and
stuff or Haiti is known to be the one
country in the world that has
the worst level of development, no
development, and no infrastructure. Wow.
So we pretty much have we're so outdated
in everything, backdated that so I know
that it is
expert have studied, you know, the story
of Haiti. So we are very much one of
I think the you know, the worst in
development and all of that. But there's
a lot of resources. The potential for it
to,
you know, to be developed and be a
resource, you know, as God would want it
to be, it's there. However, but and
again, when when you grow up in a place
like that where there is no structure,
where there is education, you know, is
so outdated. You don't even have access
so much. You have the Bible, but you
need an education system. So this keeps
people more in darkness. Okay? You you
you don't have because you're in a
survival mode. Going to church you're in
a survival mode. Going to school you're
in a survival mode. In your neighborhood
you're in a survival mode. So being in a
survival mode, can you focus on
learning? No. Not much. And so growing
up in Haiti, um
number one
reason why I had a shaky,
you know, childhood, kind of like the
foundation was shaky is because
again being in the survival mode, my
mother left me
in Haiti at the age of 3 months old.
Wow. So you were raised by the adoptive
parents then?
By by by her by her sister
and her husband. And so
So how did your mom flee? Did she leave
somewhere? Did you never see her? I did
at the age of nine. At 9 years old,
that's when I first met her. She she
left the United States. My hometown is
miles miles a few miles away from the
Bahamas. You just cross over an island,
which is part of Haiti. Behind that
island is the Bahamas. Okay. But on a
wooden boat, which is how I got to the
Bahamas, how I smuggled Wow. on a wooden
boat, you can get there in 4 days. Okay?
Whereas if you're in a speedboat or
a cruise ship, you could get there in
hours. Yeah, right.
Okay? So you that goes to show you, you
know, the situation in Haiti. And so I
my mom left me at the age of 3 months
old in the care of again a family. I
mean, we okay. We had some means, but
very little. And so
and so because of that, you didn't have
access to much, you know, education.
Yes, I went to an all girls Catholic
school because
Haiti has been a country that is,
you know, under missionary influence,
missionary, you know, donations. Most of
the things that we got for education
came from missionary. And so we had an
all girls Catholic school that was from
the Catholic Church. And so if you had a
few dollars for like my mom who was in
the Bahamas sending a few dollars, you
could afford to pay, you know, whatever
you paid to send a child like me to an
all girls Catholic school. So that's how
I, you know, I ended up in the
the Catholic school. But life at home to
to keep the family foundation or to keep
the family in the place of safety, my
grandfather, you know, who was a chief
of witches,
he had his family into ceremonies,
rituals, seances, and all of those
things. And I'm talking about deep
sacrificial blood, animal killing,
drinking of blood.
Deep. I've seen some of that stuff. Deep
deep type of things. But
to the family,
this is what we needed. You know, he's a
chief and he knew what to do to keep his
family safe. We're thinking this is
safety. We grew up thinking it's safety.
We followed not me. I mean, I'm saying
we. I'm talking about the family in
general. I was too small to even
understand. But seeing that at such a
young age and your family's accepting of
it, you had to just feel like this is
normal. It was normal.
Yeah. It was the most normal thing. Yet
I'm in school. I'm in an all girls
Catholic school.
You know, so you you you know, you have
the lies all over you. And so yeah, so
as a little child, I remember just to
fast forward, you know, with the
testimony. I remember when I when I was
of age of accountability, I was able to
understand. Maybe I was about 4, 5, 6
years old.
Once in a while, I think there was a
seasonal time
that we had to be taken to this witch
doctor, not my grandfather cuz he passed
away before I was even born. I didn't
get but I was told of all the stories
and the traditions continued with my
family. And so part of the
things that we had to do is to go to a
witch doctor and the ceremony was we had
to be put um me and my little brother
cuz it was two of us that my mom left in
Haiti.
Um, he's about a year and a half younger
than me. The two of us would be taken to
a witch doctor
somewhere
by a cemetery. He used to live in a
little mud house. Wow. And there there
was a well. There is a well in the
middle of that little mud house in the
ceremony, the drum beating and all of
that type of, you know,
witch music. Um, and then they would put
us inside that well.
Um, there's something
well like Huh? Like there's water down
there like deep well. Deep deep water
could be as high as you know,
your
chest or up to your neck. Wow. And they
would cover the well.
That's got to be terrifying for a kid.
You were a young child.
But we were not terrified.
Hm. That's the thing because we grew up
in it.
It's made to us it's presented as a
normal thing. Yeah. It's a mind control
type of thing. Wow. It's you totally
under that influence as if it's normal.
[snorts]
Okay? And so we would be put in that and
this was an, you know,
something that was done often and every
time we went the ceremony would take
place and then we come out it's and I'm
sure in their mind, you know, family
members, the grown-ups, you know, that
did that and we coming out we're we're
fine. You know,
you can't speak back to your parent even
if you saw anything wrong about it you
couldn't say anything. But to us it was
normal because we found that this was a
normal way and we would go.
You go to school something happened to
a schoolmate and you go tell your parent
we're going to go after that child. Hm.
Voodoo would be done after that child.
And you thinking, you know, you can't go
to the police, you cannot go so voodoo
is the way to deal with that situation.
You know,
and but you would never hear, you know,
the good thing that they think that
they're doing with that voodoo is, well,
maybe we'll go feed the poor. Right.
If we go feed the poor and we do that
ceremony and feed the poor but it was
still witchcraft. You know, [snorts] and
so growing growing up with that,
you know, it was just like I said a
normal way of life but you start
understanding that, you know,
once you come to maybe an environment
where things were different.
Different where people would probably be
speaking a little bit deeper. Hm. Of God
or things that don't sound like what
we're hearing at home. And you start
processing you're thinking you know,
there's something different but you
don't even know how to access what
they're saying.
Where would you hear stuff like that? Um
They would be um right in front of my
grandmother. She had a little small tiny
little
mud house, you know, also but they kind
of upgraded and put some cement around
it but it was a tiny little house. Next
to it was my mother my mother's house
which was a little bit more, you know,
better
structure. Right across from my mother
facing us is a church. Wow. A
Seventh-day Adventist Church.
Wow.
Interesting.
Right
right across from us. I remember as a
little child we would see people going
to that church. Again they have church.
Hm. But we we don't know. I you know, I
have some things that are
totally blacked out of my mind even now
I cannot even remember back from those
those days but I I think I'm probably we
would go to in front of that church
listening to those, you know, to the
songs and people
Just cuz it looked like, hey, there's
something going on. There's something
going on. So we knew that church is
going on across and then in the evening
we have that voodoo ceremony that's
going to start at midnight until 3:00,
4:00, 5:00 in the morning.
And you probably thought this
the world's just kind of blended
together probably, right? Yeah, that's
that's all it was. And also a growing up
as a child in a third world environment
with very little resources
you were every day more
the thoughts were
we got to have food to eat today. Hm.
Um, or when are we going to hear from
someone who is abroad that can send some
money? You know, Survival mode like you
were saying, yeah. Exactly. Exactly. So
it's a survival mode. So to think about
the deeper things of life that impacts
the spirit there was no, you know, you
had there was no focus on that. Wow.
It's amazing cuz
you're saying like
you're so distracted with trying to just
make ends meet just feed yourself over
here where like a spoiled nation but
we're where the other way it's like
we're partying like we're too
distracted. That was my my story was I
was just every day it was work and then
party work party. I was like, when did I
have time to think about God or
anything? And it was just one particular
day that all my friends were out of town
or had something else to do that I was
home by myself and that's when God spoke
to me in that one moment.
But but you know, Mike exactly God has a
way of
pointing himself to you. And he does it
in ways that are not common to us. Yeah.
He does it to the least expected people.
The least expected it could be an item,
you know, that you know, he's you see
something and all of a sudden something
is in your heart. He has a way of doing
that. And it's about his timing also.
Amen. It's about his timing because he
could have, you know, rescued me from
all of that. I mean, I'm going jumping
ahead a little bit. He could have
rescued me from that world of darkness
but he didn't do it until I was 37 years
old. So he allowed me to go deeper
deeper deeper into the darkness so that
when I did have an encounter with him,
you know, then I'd be totally sold out
as I am today. Amen. As I am today. But
you know, I have to say also Mike and I
I would
I I pray that the world will hear this.
Um, because during those my teenage
years I was raped. Hm. Um, well, all of
that voodoo ceremony why didn't protect
me from being raped? Right. Why did it
not protect me?
Um, as a teenager
um
15, 16 years old um not not only did I
was raped by family member.
15, 16 in high school at that time I'm
already now in the United States I'm
gang raped. Wow. I am gang raped, you
know,
you know,
in in in the United States. Yes, yeah.
All of that comes from
the nature that you carry. Yeah. Um, and
and I think that you'd understand that
once we come into relationship with
Jesus we inherit his nature. Amen. And
so because we inherit his nature we are
we do have a protection because he
protects us. Yeah. If we don't have the
nature of Jesus Christ we have the
nature of the opposite which is Satan.
Yeah. And Satan will cause things to
happen to you. So all of that witchcraft
gave me a nature that attracts things
and it attracts the rape, rejection,
abandonment
you know, lack of self-esteem, every
depression, all of that. And so so there
were so many things that I suffered. You
know, coming from that place of
witchcraft. Witchcraft is witchcraft. It
it it it it develops you into things
that build you up into more of it. You
get deeper and deeper into darkness and
the end of it is death. Yeah. The end of
it is death. And so so as a teenager
going through that
I was a lost person.
Not knowing that I'm lost. Yeah. I just
know that my life was not normal. I just
know that the place where I was it was
not good but that's all I had. I had an
environment that I could not change.
Because I depended I depended on family
member who they had they had
they knew about God but they did not
know who he was. Right. They knew there
was a God. They so they couldn't they
could not have taught me
about God. And so it was okay it is what
it is. Again
even leaving Haiti
coming across to a place that is better
developed coming to the United States.
Used I still had no knowledge of who God
is. I'm still lost.
So now I have the freedom to do even
more dark things because I'm in a place
where freedom Yeah. is given to do more
because where I was in that in in in
Haiti,
you know, parents are very strict. Not
only that you you under the influence of
witchcraft but there's a level of
strict, you know, ness in our homes
that, you know, we get away with things
here
Yeah.
that you do not get away over there. So
it's it gets even tougher. You know, you
don't have the right to ask questions
about things. You don't have the right
to in coming here now you starting to
learn about freedom. Yeah, you be a
little rebellious and stuff.
Rebellious but you still in a home that
is by culture you see that. So it makes
it tough on someone like myself or
anyone else who lives, you know, comes
from a culture like that it makes it
really tough. And so, life uh uh was
hard and I believe destiny
was playing a great part in my life.
Destiny was playing a part in my life
where um
I was not dead on purpose cuz I could
have died cuz I would
you.
I watched people in my I I watched
peers, people in my circle, you know,
who lost their lives. Yeah. You know,
due to that background in all of that.
But again, destiny,
you know, had a purpose in my life and
so um
I searched and I I searched for answers.
I asked and um
and I even started to frequent the
Catholic church, you know, since I
remember being in an all-girls Catholic
church in Haiti. Um I would go to
Catholic church, but it was just the way
that maybe this is the only place where
I could be a better person, but there
was no knowledge that I needed, Mhm. you
know, to come out of that place of
darkness. And so um
there was no strength. There was no um
balance, no boundaries, just living, you
know? So that darkness comes from when I
was born and it just engulfed me
in everything.
Um so, you know, my social life was at a
minimum, doing the best that I can. Of
course, you know, when you have the
potential, you know, to live um you you
know, you
life will take you through steps, you
know, where you get the basic things
that you need, but there's still no
influence, no godly influence.
No spiritual, you know, no no godly
influence on my life. And so I remained
um
you know, a very lost person, you know?
And it's not a place where anybody wants
to be.
Um you are in darkness, but you don't
know how do I do I identify that
darkness.
you kind of reach a place where you're
like
uh
you feel like hopeless and you're just
kind of escape through for me anyway, I
I knew
nothing I'm doing is bringing me hope or
peace,
but I I'm have to live. I was born, so
I'm just going to escape through drugs
and alcohol and sex and music and just
all these different forms of escape, but
you're still always plagued with like
there's got to be more than this.
There's got to It's funny you say this
that you you thinking there's got to be
more than this and I did not develop,
you know, that thought um until years
later that I'm better than this.
Something inside of me is telling me
uh you're better than this, you know?
But you said the word hope. Um you don't
that word never even crossed your mind.
Mhm. You know, that cuz if you can think
hope and you understand the definition
of hope, that means there's a better day
ahead.
When you are in darkness, that word
never crossed your mind. It has no
meaning. You know, it's almost like it
does not even exist in a dictionary, you
know, cuz you never hear of it. And so
it's just every day um you
And And it's like um I got to walk over
everybody else to try to, you know, I
got to
I I have to I have to step over
everything I can step over. I got to do
it I got to push through everything I
have to push through.
Takes a lot of strength and courage that
you don't even have. No. So you in a
world where nothing's to make nothing
seems to make any sense at all except
you get up every day. Well, what else
And And you start getting used to the to
to the things that you're going through.
Yeah.
You know, you start going getting used
to them, you know, rejection. Okay,
well, I know if I go through this if I
go to this place, it seems to be where I
need to be today. Well, if they reject
me, it's okay because that's all I know.
Mhm. You know, or maybe somebody's going
to abandon me again. For example, living
in that world of darkness,
you know, having that nature, you know,
you know, attracting everything that can
destroy your life, you expect that.
Okay, well, someone else is going to
rape me. What else is new? Mhm.
You know, you have a boyfriend and you
think that okay, well, all I have to do
is have sex with him and he's he's going
to be okay and you walk away. You make
that person happy and you're okay and
say okay, well, another one. So your
life become a
like a
uh
a doormat. Yeah. For everybody to walk
on, you know?
Your life become a a doormat. But
like the the that place
again with the destiny, you know, taking
you through the process, your destiny,
which you don't know,
is taking you through the process.
Somehow from time to time you will find
yourself in a place it seems like
there is something that happens in your
life that says
I think there's better. I think
something better and you want to find
that thing that is connected, make it a
little bit better.
I used to find that um in school. When I
was in high school,
um
mysteriously
um I had friends. Of course, when you
feel that you're rejected by everyone,
no one accepts you and you find one
person who actually
you know, have a genuine conversation
with you.
Yeah.
And you're like, wow, I want to hold on
to that friendship. Yeah.
I want to tie myself to that friendship.
And so there was a friend, a young girl
in high school.
Um she had a Christian
parent.
Is this a public school? Public school.
Um she she had a Christian
um
she had Christian parents. Both her
mother and father
uh were Christians and um
she would invite me to her house
sometimes.
Mhm. Thinking, wow. Wow. Somebody's
inviting me to their house? You know,
and so I would go. When I go to that
house, I would sit at a table
with the mother and the father and her
and her little sister
and they would take me in like I'm their
own little child, their own and they
would have, you know, dinner with me at
a table.
I'm thinking,
wow,
this is good. I want more of this.
Yeah. I want more of this.
I'm probably at the dinner table, they
probably saw the need, Yeah. you know,
to to to bring me to that environment. I
didn't know that, but I think they
probably if they were Christians, I am
sure
Oh, yeah. you know, that God showed them
that they needed to take me in. So often
she would bring me to her house. And And
so I remember those moments and I
cherished that friendship. But what it
does to you before you have a
relationship with Jesus Christ, you now
become codependent
Yeah. on that friendship. So that's
another level of problem.
Cuz you're sensing the peace that they
have, but you don't know where it's
coming from except that person.
Exactly. And so you become so you tie
yourself to that, which is not really
there's no balance, there's no
boundaries. So now you want that and um
and so you hold on to that relationship,
you want more of it. It's a it's the
process of searching.
Yeah. Searching for the lights,
searching for truth, all of that. Again,
it's a step-by-step process and um your
environment, your home environment, your
social environment, you know, it all
depends on that, you know, how fast will
you find that place, you know, of light.
How fast will you find, you know, that
place where you need to be to have the
life that you were born for. And so um
yeah, so it was a tough life. There's a
whole lot of other experiences that I've
had because of the witch uh craft, you
know, in my life. Um lot of other
experiences. Um
everything that could take someone to
the path of destruction, I think that um
the work of darkness, they worked it all
it worked it itself through me. Yeah.
Throughout the whole process, it did.
Got involved with the wrong crowd of
people, got into intimate relationship
with the wrong crowd. It was one thing
after another. Um and so yeah, it it it
was a tough place to be. And so again,
as we know, light in darkness, darkness
is darkness. It takes you down the path
of destruction and the end of it is
death, you know? And you keep sinning.
Yeah. You You You living in sin and
don't even know that you're living in
sin, you know? And so um sin the end of
sin, you know, a life of sin is death.
Um so you you find I find that um
uh when I came to
uh having a relationship with Jesus
Christ, I began to understand that he is
light.
And the word of God says he came into
his own and his own did not receive him.
Um he came into darkness, you know? It
came into darkness, darkness
disappeared. When I came to that
knowledge
and I came to understand I have been
living in darkness. That's why
everything of darkness have been
impacting, influencing my life. And I
made a decision, I want to live in the
light. Wow. I want the light to impact
my life. And of course, everything of
darkness start chasing after me. They're
coming even more fierce, even, you know,
with harder
um you know, things into my life. But
once I came to that knowledge and
realized
um and realized there is a better place
to be and that is to have a relationship
with Jesus Christ and I made a
commitment.
Yeah. I made a commitment, this is a
life that I want to live. Not only that
I want to live the light the the the
life, you know, in the light, I want
deep knowledge.
Because what I knew was of darkness. So
if I was getting knowledge of darkness,
now I need to know about light. Right. I
need to study about light.
Truth will make you free. Yes. How did
you Okay, so you were hanging out with
this family a lot. Is that where you
started hearing about the truth? Um I
don't I don't remember if that's where I
started hearing about it. I think the
very first time I really um heard about
truth um well,
about Jesus Christ. Um I started hearing
about Jesus Christ the very first time.
Um it was again I was 30 36 37 36 37.
I believe that family had was purposely
um God put them in my life just so I
begin to have an influence and impact.
Um A seed planted. A seed planted cuz I
cannot remember I really cannot even
remember the type of conversations we
had. I just knew that the environment
was inviting and it was a place where I
felt safe, but I cannot remember all of
the conversations that we had. So,
when in your 30s when you accepted
Christ, what were where were you getting
this knowledge from? Where were you
getting fed? Like somebody was in your
path that was sharing Christ with you
being a witness or
I think
um
I I wouldn't say that I was being fed. I
think I started to understand better
that
um
that I had a purpose and I started to um
understand there was something different
Mhm. uh something different and it was
better. And it started
it started after
I had
my first two kids. Okay.
I was in a relationship again wrong type
of people uh drug dealing Mhm. um very
dangerous
uh again, you know, I I got to a place
where the the environment changed.
Um the circle of influence influence um
was even more
dark
um impacting with um
violence Mhm. um death all around me.
People were getting killed um because of
the type of lifestyles that people were
living. Um drug dealing was very you
know, a big part of that. Um and I was
involved with one. Wow. I was involved
with one. Um I had my first two kids,
you know
you know, in in that environment. Um
And so, the way to have an identity back
then was you get involved. You start
doing what they were doing. Yeah. For
me, I was not selling the drug, but it
was around me. It was what was being
bought around me. I knew I had sense
enough to know not to get involved in
it, but I could not deny you know, um I
could not deny having the presence of it
because that's all I had the support and
all of that. So, I was right in the
middle of it. Um never had the desire to
do it, but I was right in the middle of
it. Somebody could have shot me anytime.
Yeah. Any time of day, but it did not
happen. And so,
uh
but I started helping
the person that I was involved with with
the process. Yeah. I started helping the
person because it was a life partner.
And
um and you're in a partnership in a
intimate relationship with somebody,
um you're going to help out to the
process. Yeah, it's almost like
employment. That was the work that
brought the money in and all that.
Exactly. Exactly. And so, because of
that
you know, you had
a lot of people in that social
environment that they were living right.
They were living well. It seems like you
know, they had it going on.
Uh you know, the social parties and you
know, everything seems to be you know,
well with them. But the Bible warns us.
I came to find out that the Bible warns
us about that. You know, don't think
that they're doing the book of Proverbs
you find out that just because they
appear to be rich, they're not rich. And
so, so I got involved in it by helping
to the process.
Um you know, I could have been I I was
in an I was I came to a time where I
could have been arrested.
Wow. I was right in an environment where
I should have been arrested.
And somehow I escaped it again destiny.
Sounds like God had his hand on you a
long time. Not knowing. So, destiny
again had me to escape because that time
I don't know how I did not end up for
decades in prison, but I escaped it. I'm
going back to thinking about it. And so,
in the 80s
in the 80s I was in 1980
between 1985 1986 um I got very I was
living in a depression. I had a deep
depression. I have two kids at that
time. Um
the oldest one was three 3 years old.
Um second one was about a year and a
half going into to and I was in a deep
depression and physically I was so
skinny I was skin and bones, you know,
not being able to eat, you know,
mentally disturbed and and um and of
course that person that I was in the
relationship with um he got his
superpowers by going to witch doctors.
Wow.
Talk about you know This drug dealer
guy.
Yeah. Now he's
bringing the witchcraft back in
Because that's how they get they that's
how they think they protect themselves
from being arrested.
Yeah. So, they go pay a lot of money to
witch doctors Wow. to do things to cover
them, put things on their bodies, you
know, call spirits. Mhm. You know, they
think that they walking in the
superpower that they cannot be shot,
they cannot be arrested. Yeah. You know,
they the drugs cannot be seen. You know,
none of that can be done. And so,
so as I got into depression, but my
depression was about
um you know,
um uh you know, adultery, abuse. All of
that was happening around me because you
know,
people are
living a life of um
uh polygamy. Yeah. You know, they can
have you know, a hundred women and none
of us have we can't say nothing.
Yeah. You know, because we're dominated
we're dominated. [clears throat]
So, my depression was about you know,
I'm like nothing. You know, I'm
Still feeling like a doormat.
Yes, I'm I'm like a piece of trash, you
know.
Um you have women around me, you know,
um just you you you you you you like you
have no life. You have no say so.
Whatever happens, you know it is what it
is. Take it or leave it leave it.
You know, and so that's what um that
relationship was about. So, I got
depressed. I was living in deep
depression two kids.
Uh two kids and um
and of course having friends that were
in that same environment having the same
types of boyfriends.
Mhm. They were all we were all in the
same. So, you had none we didn't know
how to
tell any each other how to get out of
it. We were still in that same influence
environment. And so, 85 again 86 86 87
um I was literally dying, you know,
mentally physically and um and that man
in my life decided, "Well, I'll take you
to Haiti." Mhm. We'll take you to Haiti.
We'll get some help. And um Why Haiti?
Cuz the witch doctors or something or
Because the witch doctors um whoever can
help me with that situation Yeah. would
have been. But I think that I was lied
to
um
even I think that depression that I had
made a way for him to take me to Haiti
again
uh to use me because there's a thing
about if you're a very smart person and
they see you smart, they feel that you
are like the a good luck person. Mhm.
And to use you as a good luck person,
they'll take you to a witch doctor and
kind of take control of your spirit so
that they can use that luck for
themselves. Wow. Okay. So, I think I was
lied to when I was told that we're going
to take you so you can see a witch
doctor to help you get better, you know,
to to be healed. And so, but I think it
was more so we're just going to sell
your soul. Wow. Because you're my you're
my lucky woman. You are my luck lucky
charm. Yeah. Okay. Um and so, that I
understood because I knew enough about
that growing up in the culture in the
environment. I knew enough about that to
know that part of that ceremony that
went on it was about that. And so, yeah,
went to Haiti. I went with him. When I
got there um
I was taken up to a cemetery.
Um when I got to the cemetery, there was
to be a three-day ceremony.
Uh three-day ceremony
uh to heal my soul.
Wow.
Um I mean, that ceremony was intense
intense to the point where I had to
drink stuff. I had to drink all type of
stuff to get me prepared. You know, I
didn't know what one day was going to
lead what the first day was going to be.
I'm given no instructions nothing.
Wow. I'm just told to do something and I
must do it.
You you
I must do it. And so, um
And so, for 2 3 days, I was in this deep
ceremony in a cemetery, all set up, you
know, um
Did you have any faith in this? Or did
you just I had no faith in it. I didn't
understand it.
But, I could not question anything.
Yeah.
Um I was not one of those young women
who had, you know, gut enough to
question why is this happening.
You know, I was lost enough. Yeah. You
know, what am I going to ask? You know,
I was lost enough. I couldn't ask. And
so, I had no faith in it, never choose
to practice it, but I'm taken into it
and it was okay. Yeah. You know.
Along for the ride.
Exactly. And so,
here I am, um you know, in that
cemetery, ceremony's going on on the,
you know, on the second day,
um I was to be buried. And I'm buried
alive.
Wow.
I'm buried alive. Uh when they took me
through, there was a lot of voodoo
dancing and, you know, people masks, you
know, uh their faces looking like
zombies and everything. I knew that cuz
I used to see those images, like we see
with this Halloween stuff that's going
on. You know, I used to see those um
images. And so, because of that, um you
know, I knew when when I saw the coffin,
they showed me a coffin,
um a banana tree with my name written on
it. That explanation they gave me. And
the explanation was, in order to buy
your soul,
you know, from whatever spirit that's
killing you, we need to bury you with
this banana tree.
We need to actually bury you, and your
soul need to stay with that banana tree.
And and once we bring you out, you know,
now you're going to live.
Wow.
You will be fine.
I believed it, because I know I'm sick.
So, I'm thinking that, okay, if I have
to go through that, you know, and I know
all of the witchcraft that were being
done in my life from a little child. So,
I'm thinking, okay,
um all right, so I'm going to be okay. I
was okay to be buried alive, you know.
just hearing it. Yeah.
And so, the ceremony and those spirits,
Mike,
for anyone listening, hearing this
testimony, hearing this story, they are
real.
There are spirits in that world of
darkness, just as we know the spirit of
the living God is real, that he is
alive. Those spirits also in the world
of darkness, they are real.
Because when they are called onto you,
when they are spoken onto you, when when
you are being introduced to them,
it comes over you, and you actually are
taken over by the spirits.
I knew it.
Yeah, because I became unconscious.
Because once they do that, I became
unconscious. You know, and so, the
burial, I know that I was buried,
um when I came out of that coffin, you
know, I guess they brought me back. They
do have power, but there's we know
there's one power, right? There is one
power that is above all that power. And
of course, God wants us to stay away
from those powers. And so, um so, when
they buried me, and um and the next step
of the ceremony was to um
bury the coffin with the banana tree
in it. My soul was to be left in the
cemetery.
So, that banana tree is still in Haiti
somewhere. Wow.
With my name written on it, in a coffin,
in that cemetery. Wow.
Okay, till today.
Um and because that's their this is
their thing. They're going to bury you,
and this is going to go down history
with them that they did something to
save somebody. Okay. And so, um so,
coming out,
but I'm totally,
um in a different place, mentally,
physically, or spiritually, what you
call the spirits at the time. Uh cuz I'm
not normal.
I'm not that person that went down in
that coffin. I'm breathing. I know
people were around me. I'm conscious
about everything, but I know something
totally different happened to me. Wow.
Uh but the belief was, this is the
process. And I'm telling them I'm not
feeling well. I'm not feeling it's part
of the Well, you have another day.
You know, we have another part of the
ceremony, the third day,
um
um you know, that third day, um at
midnight.
This is when they're going to end the
ceremony.
I was to be taken on top of a tomb in
the in the in the countryside of certain
countries, and I saw that in Bolivia
when we were there. The cemeteries are
not like small tombstone and the little
flowers. We have like those, what do you
call them, those houses, like mausoleum
type of little houses. Those are big,
you know, in in Haiti. And so, I was to
go start stand on top of one
at midnight. And at that time, they're
going to call spirits on me. I was to be
filled with those spirits, 12 of them,
12.
12 of the and each one of them had a
name. And I was to be far from the from
the everyone, and I could hear the
ceremonies. I could And they're
screaming the names and screaming what I
was to say to myself, speak to myself.
But I'm in the middle of the dark on top
of this, you know, this thing in the
cemetery, and I'm calling those spirits.
And I'm hearing all type of voices.
I'm hearing voices. I'm hearing animals.
I'm I'm hearing trouble sounds.
And those things are coming into me. I'm
hearing them.
Um and I was naked.
Totally naked as I came out of my
mother's womb, they put me on top of
because now I'm being born into
something else.
As if I was not even deeper in It's
totally a satanic counterfeit of being
born again,
Exactly.
a graveyard, I mean, Exactly. Exactly.
It It is definitely imitating exactly
what God says that he would do. You have
to be born again in the spirit. So,
their way of keeping you deeper into the
darkness or their way of keeping you
alive, you got to be born into this
thing. And so,
is a he's a deceiver. He mixes truth
with error. He can't just come out and
tell an outright lie because we'd catch
on, but you know, he always spoke
scripture to Eve. Did God not say could
eat of every tree? You know, he he spoke
scripture to Jesus.
And so, you know, he's he's taking what
God has made and perverting it. You have
to die to the old you. They buried
Exactly.
you. They had a rebirth. Yeah.
And so, wow, it's man, it's amazing.
Like I just want to clarify that because
like, you know, the New Age and the
occult, people get sucked in because it
sounds so close to the truth. Like in
fact, the New Age is like I have books
for research on New Age, and it's
literally scripture. Tons of it.
Yeah. We're going to reach Christ
consciousness and and all these things.
But that's how that's how so deceptive
because it's so close.
Mhm. But you know why, um it's because
the word of God is power.
The word of God is alive. And and
God says it.
His word is powerful. He knows that the
sun has power. He knows that the moon
has power. He knows that everything that
he created, everything that God created
has power.
But he warns us that we have our limit.
We should not be worshipping those
things. We should not use those powers.
You know, you know, we should not we
should not lean on those things as a way
of life. He gives them power, you know,
he has power in creation, but not for us
to imitate him as gods.
To control other people's life, you
know, that's not what it is. A tree was
created powerful enough to grow from the
ground, to produce fruit for us to have
food to eat. For us to have leaves for
medicine.
to serve us. Exactly. But you don't go
and serve the gods of the trees.
Yeah. It doesn't make sense. And so, so
Satan uses, of course, we know he's an
imitation. He imitates God. And so, he
takes this thing all the way to the
left, you know, trying to get peo- and
he gets people lost into it. And people
look for that power because why? They're
denying God. So, if you deny God, then
you're going to accept, you know, what
Satan says. And so, that's
that's that's the idea behind that world
of darkness, you know, [clears throat]
that people use. And so, so my going
back to and, you know, I can end my
testimony with that to speak about, you
know, how people come to live a life
where, you know, you have no no
strength. You you really have no
strength, no power, cuz I'm going to be
speaking about a skeleton life
as I know it, biblically speaking. You
know, and so, coming from that cemeter-
cemetery
on that day, that that night, um
I knew that I was possessed.
Now, you're hearing the voices and
everything.
I'm hearing them. Nightmares. I was not
normal. I was not normal. How I got in
that airplane to get to Haiti, to get to
that place of that ceremony, those 3-day
ceremony, getting back on back on that
airplane, I knew that I was not going
back home. I was in a worse state.
I was sick physically.
I was having deep depression. Now I'm
mentally sick, and I don't know how to
explain it to anyone.
And the people that I knew, you know, I
dare not say anything because this man
that was in my life, you know, he had um
he had very powerful influence around
him.
I dared not expose what was going on.
But I um
I knew enough to tell him that I'm not
well.
I'm even worse than I was. Something is
totally wrong. Well, he took me to
another voodoo priest. Wow.
When I got to Miami, he took me to
another voodoo priest. And um that
voodoo priest says, "I need to spend
another 3 days with her." Wow.
And he left me there.
With that other voodoo voodoo priest,
you know, um and uh that voodoo priest
was again to rape me sexually.
Wow. Because that's part of the, you
know, that was part of his part of the
healing. At that point, I was sick
enough to say, "You know, I don't care
if I die right now.
You're not going to touch me." Mhm. I
was powerful enough to say, "I might
die,
but I'm going to die saying you will not
touch me." Mhm.
I told him that. And so,
but the man left me there anyway.
He left me with that voodoo priest. Wow.
Um
and instead of raping me, sleeping with
me,
um he did another part of witchcraft.
He boiled a rock. Mhm.
He boiled He says, "If you cannot sleep
with me."
And I think that was an intent to hurt
me because I would not let him have
sexual, you know, intercourse with me.
Um he boiled a black rock
and he inserted it inside of me.
Wow.
Wow. And he took it out with his hand.
He wrapped it um
in a piece of paper.
Before he wrapped it in that piece of
paper,
he sent me to another cemetery.
Wow. This is all in Florida, in Miami,
Florida now.
Sent me to another cemetery
with a piece of paper
in my underwear.
And he sent some of his people to
accompany me
that I was to be in front of a cross
because they have cross. Mhm. They call
it bawo.
That's the name of it. So, anyone who is
into witchcraft know what bawo is if you
say bawo. So, um at midnight, I was to
be in front of that cross, no earlier,
no no later. At midnight, I had to be by
that cross and I was to stand in front
of that cross.
And I was to to speak certain things and
things were going to put over me and
then I would leave the cemetery.
When I leave the cemetery, I would go
by the ocean.
I have to go by the ocean and renounce
whatever it is they did to me. Oh, wow.
Yeah, all of that in one night. I had to
go by the ocean and renounce
um whatever they did did to me. Um I had
to go throw a coconut with a big gold
chain in it. Yes, that was put in my
neck because that big gold chain was
uh I don't Anyway, so
stuff. All of that. And so, um so I did.
When I got to the ocean, I had to
calculate so many feet away from the
ocean and
um
to walk backward.
Mhm. I have to walk backward. Walking
backward means I'm not facing the
spirits. Mhm.
So, I'm walking backward,
um you know, going to the ocean and take
the gold neck chain out of my neck and
put it in the coconut and throw it in
the
in the ocean. Did all of that and I had
to be by him before 1:00 in the morning.
All of that had to be done. And when I
came back to him, um you know, he would
take the paper, not me. He would take
the paper out of my underwear. When he
opened that paper, there was some
handwriting on it.
That wasn't there before? No. Wow.
It's real. Yeah. It is real. Mhm. It it
it it's it's real and people are saying,
"No, it it does it doesn't take all
that." Well, I lived it and it is real.
Ouija boards, tarot cards, stay away
from all that stuff, man. Stay away. It
is real.
Uh they have power, but it's not the
power of God.
And it's going to lead you to
destruction. Exactly. And so, um
in that paper, there was a handwriting,
something I've never seen.
It's not anything I've never seen. I
don't understand it. Mhm. Um apparently,
through the process of manifesting in
those spirits, the spirits had their way
or whatever that was in me. I don't know
what it was. And so, when I came back is
when he took that rock, that black rock,
and he wrapped it around that paper. I
was to take that rock wrapped up in the
paper and keep it next to me wherever
I'm going to sleep. Mhm.
I'm going to sleep. Um and I still
thought that something really maybe
because seeing that handwriting in that
paper, I'm thinking something is real
here.
Right. Something is real because that
paper had nothing on it. And so, here I
am now, if I left that rock somewhere,
I'm thinking I'm lost. I'm thinking
something's going to happen to me.
faith in this in that rock.
rock, yeah.
Okay? And so, it is around me um
forever. Cannot remember when I got rid
of it. Um
but at a certain point, I got rid of
that rock because I didn't see anything
good happening with it and all of that.
But all of that um take you to a place
where the life
that and so much more, Mike, so much
more happened to me that again, all of
that would be in my book for someone to
read, but this is enough to tell you
that, you know, someone's body
going through that process from
a child, you know, from birth um to
an adult,
you know,
it's no joke. Yeah. It's no joke and you
are living a life that appears to be
normal with people or sometimes you get
yourself into situations where people
know
"This is not good for her, but she got
herself got herself into that." Now you
start getting the blames. Yeah. Now you
start getting the pointing of finger.
Now you start getting people laughing at
you. Mhm. You know, and so um so living
that life
is um it leads again to death. Yeah. Cuz
you don't understand it and you don't
have anything to lean on. You don't have
anyone that you know that can tell you
somewhere along the way,
um
I might have met someone who would speak
about prayer,
but I don't know if it made any sense.
Right.
You know, I don't know if it made any
sense. I started going to Catholic
church just because I knew
that I used to go to church. That
probably did something for me. I went to
church, but there was nothing for me to
get from there Yeah. to help me with
with the life that I was going through.
Um and so,
um
I started to prosper at a certain place.
And I believe because the influence of
making money, Mhm. the drug dealings and
everything, um it's there. So, it's an
influence. So, you go back to that place
and say, "Well, if I'm going to make
money, um I can do this. I can do that."
Um and then there were things that were
introduced to me. I was invited, you
know, to get involved,
um you know, in in certain things
socially and um things that would
produce money. It and it's like maybe
those spirits probably were trying to
show themselves strong, Is it like
multi-level marketing and stuff?
Multi-level marketing, not only
multi-level marketing. I I believe that
I was smart enough also to get involved,
you know, cuz you know, going to school,
I had a high school diploma, you know, I
was pretty much I could articulate
myself very well
places. So, some people saw some things
in me, you know, that was worth putting
me in a work environment, Yeah. you
know, where I can produce and
everything. So, I started doing well in
the corp in the work environment and
stuff. And then I find that
um you know, I had resources, money
resources coming to me whether it was
legal or illegal, things were coming to
me. Things were just being introduced to
me. Money opportunities were coming from
all different and then So, I got used
to, "Wow, I can make money. I can do
things and I'm needed. Mhm.
I'm wanted." Yeah. So, you start doing
these things, you know, and uh to the
point where uh while I'm still dealing
with all those spiritual influence,
um you know, I had opportunities to meet
people, you know, who were wealthy
and they saw my skills, that I was
intelligent enough, you know, to
introduce me to certain platforms, um
you know, to help me and I saw
opportunities that were right open
before me and I started taking them.
Um and I became a business person. I
developed in the professional world,
still under the influence, Yeah.
you know, of all those spirits, still
under the influence.
Um I became my own business owner. I
owned um an insurance insurance agency.
I was the very first Haitian woman, you
know, who developed my own insurance,
you know, business and was very well
known. That gave me an identity.
That gave me something, you know, in my
community,
um
but I didn't know how to manage all of
that. Still, I have no balance. Yeah. I
don't have
I don't have a foundation. I I knew it
all
because at that point, I knew enough to
know that everybody else around me, I
knew better because I'm a business
owner. Mhm. I'm thro I'm you know, I'm
thriving, you know, I'm thriving. I'm
doing things where I'm making a lot of
money. I can have whatever I want. I can
drive whatever car I wanted to drive. I
can get my children the best. I can
support families now. I became somebody.
Wow. I became somebody until the
business started to
Yeah. Doors begin to close.
That's how a lot of people get sucked
into this stuff, you know, into the
occult and stuff. They They start doing
the ceremonies, the rituals, and it
eventually pays off, it seems like, but
then there's always a downside. Yeah.
Yeah. And I I think again destiny steps
in. Yeah.
Um God steps in. Amen. You know, through
destiny and say, "My appointed time has
come." You know, the in the story of
Abraham,
um you know, he raised Abraham as the
father of faith and also through
Abraham, all families of the earth will
be blessed. Yeah. Sounds like, you know,
familiar to me
um that I'm going to be blessed and I'm
thriving and I'm thriving I'm getting,
you know, and so but he told Abraham um
even when it came time for him to bless
Abraham with Isaac as the son of
promise. He's the father of faith.
Through him all families will be
blessed. So, Isaac is going to be born,
but he sent an angel
to Abraham, right? To tell Abraham at
the appointed time, "I will come back."
Yeah. Right? He did not just give him
that son at that time. At the appointed
time. So, the appointed time will come.
And the appointed time came when he
showed up and told Abraham, "You're
going to have a son." And it happened.
So, I think to all of us, God will show
up at a time. You'll have that voice.
However, by whatever means that he's
going to talk to you and say, "I'm
coming back." Yeah. And you're waiting
for him to come back. And so, at that
time
um that the business was thriving and
I'm doing well, I mean, I could have
anything anything that I wanted cuz I
was doing so well financially. Uh but
that money that I was making uh the
things that I possessed um was not that
what they were not blessings of God.
Yeah. You know, it was Satan that wanted
to keep me in that place of darkness.
And so um in Psalm chapter 10, some
people don't think that Satan can bless
you. Oh, yeah. Some people will say,
"No." Yeah, for Jesus all the kingdoms
of the world.
Exactly. So, so he knows how to imitate
God again, you know, to bless people.
And so um
in Psalm chapter 10, he says that Satan
lurks in low. He lurks in dark places,
in hidden places, you know, and he
creeps around and he blesses the needy.
Mhm.
Wow. That is in Psalm chapter 10. He
blesses the needy. Yes, Satan bless
people. Yeah. That's not the blessings
of the Lord. Yeah. That's an imitation
of the blessings of God. It's a bribery.
It's a scheme. Exactly. So, yes, I was
being blessed. Yes, he wanted to show me
who I am because um Satan knows that
when a person is on purpose, God has a
plan. So, he's going to imitate that to
show you you can do well. He brings
wealth. Like you said, he did that to
Jesus. He brings the wealth and you
don't know that. You embrace the wealth,
you get involved in it, and you're being
blessed. But in my um in my journey when
I got to that
uh a place where
I believe it was time for God to say,
"Now that I've shown you enough about
you,
who you are,
what you're able to endure,
why you suffered, Mhm. why you able to
make money, the gifts that I have in
you." I didn't understand it then.
Um I think he came at that appointed
time Yeah. and said, "It's time for me
to knock all of that out of your life."
That knocking was hard. Ooh. The Bible
says The Bible says that the word of God
is like a hammer. Yeah. Oh my God,
Mikey. Mhm. The word of God is like a
hammer. He says he comes like fire Mhm.
and like a hammer.
What does that mean? God will use his
word like fire to burn everything off of
you. Mhm.
He will destroy everything by his word
like fire.
And he will turn those things into ashes
so that they never come back over you
again.
He will use his word like a hammer to
take you out of that mold of witchcraft.
Mhm.
So, he came. He showed up
and began to turn everything. I didn't
understand it.
Oh, no. Didn't understand it.
I have an identity. I know people.
What's wrong with you, God? I have three
different luxury cars in front of my
house. I own a house. I have I'm showing
off. Yeah. My neighbor sees me now. You
know,
what are you doing?
So, in that business as the doors begin
to close,
money was not coming anymore. Every
source every source of money shut down.
Every door.
Uh
and I thought, "Wow."
I said, "Okay, I'm going to call for a
voodoo priest." Mhm.
I paid money to get one from Haiti
to bring to my business. Wow. Um
had a good friend um who used to visit
with me and um and the person said, "I
can get you one. I know one who's very
powerful." And I said, "Okay, how much
does it cost?" I had money. I said, "How
much does it cost? I'm going to go ahead
and um
you know, I'll I'll pay to get him."
And flew him over from Haiti to come to
Miami. Um shut my business down one day.
I said, "Let's get this thing done.
Let's reopen those doors. Let's get me
back into the flow of money." So, this
voodoo priest came with my friend and
we're in the back of my office and we're
doing all of that witchcraft and he had
a little aluminum plate and and he began
to put fire. He's raising up fire and
throwing all of these things in it.
Something picked me up from the inside
and said, "Tell that man to get out of
here." Whoa.
I got up. I got up. I kicked that
aluminum plate with the fire. Don't know
why the place didn't burn that day. I
had file cabinets.
I was selling insurance. This is back in
the days we didn't have internet access
where things were, you know, paperless.
I have files everywhere.
Kicked that I mean that plate with the
fire and I said, "Get out." Wow. Leave
now. Enough.
Kicked both of them out of the and I got
on the phone and I screamed.
And I cried. And I cried. And I'm I
cried. I'm like, "Okay, that's it.
This is it. There's nowhere else to
nowhere else to turn. I don't know what
else to do."
So, I kicked that man out
out of the place and at that point I
said, "Okay,
I don't know what else to do.
Have no idea, you know, where to go from
here."
Um
and I collected myself.
Collect myself back. And I thought,
"I got to do something."
I have a cousin
um
who lived in New Jersey.
Um couple of days later, she came from
New Jersey to Miami to visit and she
came to my business to my office to
visit.
And I'm telling her what I'm going
through. She passed away now.
Uh she passed away and um so she
fulfilled, you know, in my life.
So, she passed away and
um
and she said,
"Why don't you move to New Jersey? Come
to me."
And I thought, "Okay, that'll work.
That will work
cuz I don't know anyone.
I don't have to face anyone. I don't
have to be put to shame."
It's a fresh start.
Fresh start. I don't care what it takes.
I will I will move.
And I start making, you know, packing my
things and making decisions and to go.
And I really left in a way where, you
know, I fixed nothing. I was in a place
where there was no There is no way There
was no way to fix anything. Things were
so bad that I could not put anything
back together. So, I just walked away.
You know, I left I did leave some people
into situations that I knew that were
beyond me, but I couldn't explain.
I could not explain what was going on.
Um and so I left. I was just trying to
find a place to hide.
Um and of course a lot of people thought
when I left Miami, they thought I went
to prison. Oh, yeah. Excuse me, because
people thought that I They knew what I
was you know, what I was in, people that
I was involved with. And so they
thought, you know, I must have gotten
myself into some federal situation and
all of that, but they had no idea what
was going on. So, packed up my things um
I took my two oldest At that point I
have three kids.
Um packed up my things to take took the
little one my um my little daughter, she
was 5 years old, and I left the two
oldest ones
um with family members and I thought,
"Let me go ahead and establish myself in
a place and I'll come back, you know,
for my kids." Um
So, I went to New Jersey. Um I started
um an entry-level receptionist job at an
insurance company, right up my level of
experience and skills, you know, just
for minimum wage.
Um I went um but
I didn't have enough to support my life.
Not coming from, you know, living
financially, you know, the way I was
living and having a job where I was
getting paid $10 an hour.
You know, how do you feed three kids?
Huh? You know, how do you feed yourself,
put gas in your car, and and stuff like
that. And so um
So, I got this entry-level job at an
insurance company in New Jersey.
Um
and I began to get depressed again.
The depression started coming back.
Um
and there was a young lady
who worked who was in a cubicle next to
me
um who would um introduce me to prayer
every day.
Um but I was getting upset.
The last thing I wanted to hear was
prayer. Mhm. Who are you to think, you
know, that you can help me? Yeah. You
know, and of course I was very private
at the time. I'm not telling anyone. The
only person who kind of knew in New
Jersey what I was going through was my
cousin. You know, cuz I was staying with
her for a while. And so when this person
started talking about prayer, you know,
I'm rebuking her. I'm like, you know,
you know, get away from me. Stop. And
I'm yelling and screaming, you know,
because I had voices inside of me, you
know, speaking other things to me. And
now you're telling me about prayer. What
is this thing about prayer? And of
course I would hear her conversation
with other people. She was Pentecostal.
Okay? So, you know how they get deep
into
prayer and you know, the deep things of
the spirit and very energetic and
everything. I'm thinking, I don't need
this.
I don't need this, but daily
daily she would talk to me about prayer.
Daily. And um
and I'm constantly, you know, rejecting
and getting away from her. A year later,
Mike, a year later, 1999, I moved to New
Jersey.
Um
May 8th, 1998.
A year later uh sometime around October
um I knew this was it. I couldn't take
it anymore.
Could not take it anymore and I thought,
this is it. I got to end my life.
Oh, man. I I got to end my life. Um you
know, I I there's there's no other
reason for me to live. I got to end my
life. And so um
just as I was preparing myself that day
you know, to take my life and my
children's life.
Um
there was a knock on my door. I was
stirring a poison. Wow. I was stirring a
poison. I'm going to take poison with my
kids, you know, to end my life. And um
guess who came to visit on that day
knocking on the door? That friend.
girl in the cubicle next to you? And her
name was Hope. Huh.
Hope. Wow.
Her name was Hope.
She knocked on the door and when she
came
and that's when I came face-to-face
with, you know, my destiny helper, you
could call it.
You know, and um
and I just dropped on her chest. Wow.
And I screamed for my life.
And she held me and
she took me to um to her place and
you know, just took care of me for that
day. Wow. Um but I went to another place
that day. I don't know what happened. I
I couldn't figure out what happened. I
couldn't figure out. I could not put the
day together. All I know is that
I don't know what's going to happen now.
Hm. You know, and but I knew that Hope
on that day
you know, was my saving grace if you
call it. And so um so I went to her
house
and she prayed with me and uh took care
of me for that day. Um most of those
things are blocked from my conscious. I
don't even remember the whole process
because it was an intense situation in
my life. You know, my life was
intensely, you know,
uh influenced by by that world of
witchcraft and darkness. And so so that
Sunday morning, the next day
um
I felt different. I felt somewhat, you
know, a bit relieved. I'm not dead.
Yeah. So whatever it is that kept me
alive
I thought, I'm going to visit that
Catholic church.
Um it was the name of it was Sacred
Heart Sacred Heart.
I went to visit that church.
You know, and I said, okay. Well, if
there is a God
who saved my life, I'm going to go
um
and um can I see what happens from
there.
So I went to church after Catholic
church. I'm coming up my steps to my
apartment to that place where I lived.
And halfway up the steps, there was a
voice
um that said, for the sake of
friendship, why don't you visit her
church?
You are alive today because of her. So
why don't you visit her church? I turned
around.
Turned around and went to her church.
Wow. I went to a Pentecostal church.
Never been to a Pentecostal church. So I
walked to the doors and uh I'm seeing
all of that energy and I said, this is
not church.
[laughter]
This cannot be church. It doesn't make
sense. It's not church.
And so um so I went to church and of
course I'm acting up and the rebellious
person that I am, I'm trying I'm like
I'm looking at the pastor. I'm looking
at everybody making all these fools.
And I'm looking at Hope behind me cuz
she was an usher in the church and I'm
pointing finger at her because the
message
that the pastor was preaching that day
was directly into my situation.
Um so while we're finding truth today,
uh we're finding a better place of
learning, more discipline through the
process of God rescuing us. He takes us
to those different places.
It may not be a ultimate place of
learning to find the truth, the truth
that we need, but he'll take us to the
process that we're going to hear.
He can if he can make a donkey to speak.
That's right.
If he can make a donkey to speak, so
at that church, I went and the pastor
was speaking directly into my situation.
So I've never heard that before. Never
understood what a sermon, you know, how
deep a sermon can get. I'm looking at
Hope. I'm thinking, how dare you tell
this man everything about my life. Oh
yeah, I wanted to choke her that day.
I'm thinking, how dare you? You know,
because at that point, I'm I'm ready to
live now. You know, I'm ready to live.
I'm ready to fight everything that's
coming against me. So not even you going
to tell this pastor, you know, about me.
And so
and so I told her
and she said, no. She used to call me
Mimi. She says, no, Mimi, just sit back.
And they had me at the front of the
church.
Right under the pastor's breath.
[laughter] And so so she said, just sit
down. Listen, it's the Holy Spirit
talking to you. I'm like, okay. All
right, Holy Spirit, talk to me.
I want to hear. But somehow to the
through the rest of that service, I was
subdued.
Um you know, I started paying attention.
And I started manifesting in whatever I
was experiencing, I'm sure it was the
power of God at that time. He's making
himself known to me.
When I left that church when I left that
church that day, I remember
the environment
was better.
The trees were greener.
People look good. I'm like, okay,
something happened today.
I need more of that. Didn't understand
the depth of it, but I need more of
that. And so I believe it was the next
Sunday after or maybe the second week
after the, you know, I was ready to be
there in that place to hear that pastor
again.
I wanted to hear that pastor again to
see if he's still going to be speaking
truth, you know, speak speak something
that I needed to hear. And there I was
ready to embrace whatever that was, you
know, I was ready to embrace that power.
I was ready to say yes. And I understand
that it was Jesus Christ
that I faced on that day. And um so I
was first you know, in front of the
pastor when he made the altar call. I
was first in front of him. I said, I
want that.
I opened my arm. I said, I want that.
And Mike
the power
of God
instantly
overtook me.
I knew
I knew on that day
that I became a new person.
Um I wanted more.
He gave me a hunger on that day.
He gave me a thirst on that day. I'm
calling everybody that same day.
I started calling everybody that I knew.
I started calling all the hypocrites
who were in my life talking about God. I
said, did you know about this? Did you
know about this? I said, I just learned
this. Now I wanted a Bible. I need
somebody to give me a Bible.
Hope got me a Bible.
And so I started reading the Bible. And
so from there I made a commitment that I
am going to serve you, God.
I am going to serve you because you are
real.
From this time forward, take my hand
and lead me.
There is a place of a still small voice,
a quiet place. If you allow him
he will speak to you.
If you will hear our testimonies
if you want to live
if you know that you were born, you were
destined to live
you can live.
You can live. If you feel that you've
been weak like those skeletons
you've lost your strength
you have all the money in the world. You
have everything that you need, but
somewhere you feel so weak and it
doesn't seem as if there is no doctor
there is no professional
there is no source
anything in life that can bring you
strength. If [music] that is you
I am here to tell you that he is
willing.
And he is able to reach [music] you in
that place. And he will speak to you in
his own place because he has [music]
created an environment already. Each one
of us, every single person has a unique
place of meeting with him.
And it is my prayer today
that you will hear this word
and that you will allow [music] him
to take you out of that place of doing
things in your own way, celebrating, you
know, celebrating him
instead of celebrating those things in
the world. So, I encourage you today to
seek the light.
Seek the light [music] and let that
become a part of your life and take it
from there. And I pray that you become a
person [music]
who will pray to God and ask you to
maintain that relationship with him so
that you can [music] live in light and
celebrate the light instead of darkness.
Amen. Thank you so much for sharing that
powerful testimony with us. I hope you
guys were blessed like it by it the way
I was. I mean,
it's a really a redemption story to show
that we're never too far gone for God.
You can be in the depths of witchcraft
[music]
and God still wants you. He desires you.
He's going after you. He loves you.
And he he'll try everything he can to
get your attention. He's in that still
small voice. He comes to bring you life
and life more abundantly. He wants to
pull you out of that darkness that leads
[music] to death and destruction.
I just pray that you guys would share
this with any family and friends that
need to hear this message. And if you
were blessed by it, give it a thumbs-up.
It really helps get this [music] uh
video out into the algorithm so more
people can see it. If this is your first
time and you're not a subscriber,
[music] please click that subscription
so that you can catch videos like this.
We have lots of videos about all kinds
of tough topics
[music]
and just uh we analyze the world through
the lens of the Bible and we hear great
testimonies. We're so glad you were with
us and we'll see you guys next time on
LED Live.
[music]
There has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world. And in
1999, a movie titled The Matrix hit the
world stage. These stories are often
told and seen over and over again. Is it
simply just to make money?
Or is there something more nefarious
behind it?
[music]